ALI AFSHAR: Hi everyone.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
My name's Ali.
STEVE BAZYL: And I'm Steve.
ALI AFSHAR: And today we're
going to be talking to you
about all the exciting
things going on at
Google I/O this year.
If you don't know Google I/O,
it's our main developer
conference, and we're really
excited about it.
So, if you want a quick overview
of what we're doing
at Google Drive, then make sure
you go to the Google I/O
website, which has the sessions
listed on there, and
you can see that now.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, so if you
haven't checked that out yet,
I want to give you a couple
highlights of some of those
sessions that we're doing
related to Google Drive.
There's one which is a You're
On With Drive SDK.
This is with Nicholas.
And he is just going to review
all the changes since last
year's I/O. There's been a lot
of developments with the SDK.
And for those who just want to
catch up, it's a great talk.
There will be a few others.
I'm doing one with Josh
Hudgens, who 's our PM
on the Drive SDK.
And we're going to talk about
some of the momentum that
we've seen over the last year,
the growth in drive apps, and
how you, as a developer, can
take advantage of that.
Brian and Cheryl, who were on
GDL a few weeks ago talking
about the real time API,
are going to do a deep
dive into that API.
It's actually a really good
talk for those who are
interested in how that
technology works.
Very technical.
Very interesting talk.
They're also going to do a code
lab on Friday, the last
day of I/O, where you can play
with the real time API and
learn how to build an app.
There are several talks on Apps
Scripts, and how Apps
Scripts integrates with
Google Drive.
You can do things like
automating Google Docs, and
also build drive apps using
the Apps Script APIs.
And Ali, I think you're doing
one on app data, right?
And Android development.
ALI AFSHAR: That's right.
Plug for my talk.
I think Drive's a really
great solution for
storing files on Android.
And we're going to talk about
the various ways you can do
that, and why you
should do that.
So, come along to that
talk as well.
Thanks, Steve.
STEVE BAZYL: And there are a few
more that will be on the
schedule as I/O appears
to get closer.
But those are being kept
a little quiet for now.
But check them out.
Really exciting stuff coming.
And, of course, you can always
come and watch the sessions.
You're encouraged to.
If you happen to miss one of
them, but you want to ask
questions, you can stop
by the Office Hours.
After each talk, the speakers
are going to be there.
And you can come and get more
information, or ask questions,
for whatever you need.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah, and we love
talking to you guys.
So, please come along.
You can't stop us from talking
about programming, and the
various things involved
with Google Drive.
So, please, please just come
along there and see us.
Now, if you haven't got
a ticket, don't worry.
There are many ways you can
still get involved.
We have Google I/O Extended.
Now, that's hundreds of places
where people have organized to
have events around I/O. So, if
you have one local to you,
then please get involved
there.
You can see the map
of all the places.
And, again, that's on our
Google I/O website.
STEVE BAZYL: And people are
watching these live, right?
So people in Sydney, you're
going to be watching at two or
three in the morning.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah, it's a
pretty fun occasion.
So if you can get involved
there, I certainly would.
And, again, even if you can't
make that, don't worry.
We're recording all
these sessions.
And we're live streaming a
number of them, as well, on
Google Developers Live.
So, if you come here while
you're watching this site, you
can see all the sessions
that you miss.
Even if you go to the conference
and you miss some
sessions because of conflicts,
you can always catch up there.
STEVE BAZYL: And if you are
going to be at I/O, I
definitely encourage
you to check out
the Developer Sandbox.
This is near the Office
Hours, as well.
And there will be 24 different
developers who have built apps
around Google Apps, including
Drive, and Apps Script, and a
few other APIs.
And check these out.
The list of developers that will
be on there is going to
be available later today.
I don't want to spoil the
surprise too much.
But there's some really
cool apps in there.
These people are building really
innovative things.
We have a broad set from desktop
applications, to
hardware, to web apps, some
really interesting
integrations with Apps Script.
And these are all developers.
So you come by, ask them about
their implementation.
They can answer questions.
Give you some advice on how
to make your applications
integrate really nice.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah, and
also ask them why.
What did Google Drive
integration for their apps,
what did that do for
their business?
Because that's really
important.
We want you to make money.
And these are people who are
making good money out of
having Google Drive
integration.
So, come along and say
hello to them.
And lastly, some fun stuff.
So, of course, we'll be having
the usual set of tastefully
branded merchandise with
the Google Drive logo.
So, come along and get that, if
you come and see us in the
Sandbox or the Office Hours.
And in addition to that this
year, we're having prizes for
posts to the community.
So, every day at I/O, we'll be
giving a special prize to one
post from someone who's at I/O.
And if you're not at I/O,
don't worry.
You can still win a prize for
a post to the community from
someone who's not at I/O.
So, make a post.
Make it the most interesting
thing you can--
something you learned, something
you'd like to know.
We'll be giving a prize out
for the best one of these.
Just tag your post with Drive
I/O hashtag, and everything
else will fall into place.
So, come, win those prizes.
We're really excited
to see you there.
STEVE BAZYL: Yep, it's going
to be a great time.
We're really looking
forward to it.
And if you're going to be there,
definitely stop by and
say hello to us at
the Office Hours.
Stop by the sessions.
And check out the developers
in the Sandbox And, of
course, have fun.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah, awesome.
Definitely have fun.
Enjoy yourselves at I/O.
So, we'll see you
there, if you're coming.
If not, hopefully next year.
STEVE BAZYL: Thank you.
ALI AFSHAR: Thanks all.